hoy firmó Justice gobernador del estado
de Virginia occidental esta ley y pone
de inmediato la aplicación de esta ley
en 90 días las penalidades asociadas a
esta vigencia occidental se convierte
entonces en el segundo estado en Estados
Unidos en prohibir el aborto después de
que la Corte Suprema de Justicia Pues
fallara en contra del derecho al aborto
a nivel Federal hay que mencionar que
las excepciones a esta ley son la
violación el incesto y riesgos de salud
en la madre sin embargo los abortos se
tendrán que hacer en las primeras ocho
semanas en caso de adultos o 14 semanas
en caso de menores los médicos que se
atrevan a Pues proveer los abortos
corren el riesgo de durar 10 años en la
cárcel y este tema es bastante
importante teniendo en cuenta que las
encuestas recientes dicen que el tema
del aborto es el que más participación
ha generado tanto en la población
votante demócrata y republicana Así que
va a ser un tema muy importante para las
elecciones legislativas en noviembre y
presidenciales en dos años
Cristóbal hablemos ahora de otro tema
que vuelve a generar polémica es la
crisis migratoria y la interna entre
republicanos y demócratas decenas de
migrantes que esta semana fueron
enviados a la isla de marta's en
Massachusetts por orden del gobernador
de Florida fueron hoy trasladados de
nuevo a una base militar cercana como lo
sabían recibido los habitantes de Marta
banger a los migrantes Y qué será de la
suerte de ellos ahora
Pues los envía precisamente a Marta
militar de inicialmente
desde Texas porque según el gobernador
de santos de la Florida Pues allá están
las élites de Estados Unidos las élites
progresistas y demócratas y según el
gobernador de la Florida Pues lo hacía
para que se dieran cuenta un poco lo que
viven los estados fronterizos al recibir
esta población migrante santis decía que
enviaba a estos 50 migrantes en dos
aviones desde Texas hasta Massachusetts
no pasando por la Florida que es lo que
cuestiona mucha gente precisamente para
que las élites se dieran cuenta lo que
es vivir con inmigrantes a todo el
tiempo en sus estados es de Resaltar sin
embargo y lo critican mucho acá en
Washington que rompes Pues dice que las
élites tienen que vivir lo que está
viviendo los estados fronterizos sin
embargo pues rondentes estudió en
Harvard hace parte de la élite
estadounidense estos migrantes en su
mayoría venezolanos están ya entonces en
la base militar de keiko también en
Massachusetts donde van a recibir pues
ayuda médica donde van a atender van a
tener obviamente acceso a comida
vivienda y van a estar allá en los
próximos días mientras que se les Define
su estatus migratorio es Resaltar que
pues en las últimas semanas se calcula
que han sido cerca de 12 millones de
dólares lo que los gobernadores de los
estados fronterizos se han gastado
enviando migrantes a ciudades como
Washington como Nueva York como Chicago
precisamente para eso para mostrarle a
las personas de estas ciudades pues lo
que se vive en la frontera la alcaldesa
de Washington precisamente tuvo que
decretar estado de emergencia para poder
atender a los más de 10.000 migrantes
indocumentados que han llegado a la
capital estadounidense